this being the hundredth anniversary of
the development of motion pictures it
seems fitting that we end our
celebration with the award that
recognizes the highest achievement in
filmmaking this year during the course
of the show you've seen segments of the
five films for Best Picture and each one
is a remarkable combination of vision
and dedication the five nominated
pictures are awakenings Walter F Parkes
and Lawrence Lasker producers
Dances with Wolves Jim Wilson and Kevin
Costner producers
ghost Lisa Weinstein producer The
Godfather Part three Francis Ford
Coppola producer Goodfellas Berwyn
Winkler producer and the Oscar goes to
Dances with Wolves jr. Kevin Costner
like oh my god
I didn't drink any water with smart
oh I would like to thank the Academy
members for the culmination of what has
been one incredible dance for me over
the past four years and all of us - a
cast and crew who never said never you
can't do it
- Orion Pictures and majestic films
International for their never-ending
support on a film that was difficult
- our staff at TIG productions - my wife
Teresa a family and friends who kept me
honest roll this into the Native
American nation throughout this
wonderful country whose drum continues
to beat and will beat forever and - my
two best friends Kevin Costner and
Michael Blake allow me to participate in
this thank you
I just want to say that it's very easy
for people to trivialize what we do
sometimes and they do it in ways of
saying well if it's such a big deal how
come nobody remembers who last year won
the Oscar and I've got a real flash for
you I will never forget what happened
here tonight my family will never forget
what happened here my Native American
brothers and sisters across the country
especially the coat of Sioux will never
forget people I went to school with will
never forget Dances with Wolves won this
year and while it's not as important as
the rest of the world situation where it
sits it will always be important to us
and we thank you for this
you